for people that don't have a great life
that do have debt that do have worries
that do have health concerns maybe the
reality of spending time with someone's
becoming less appealing because of how
appealing the digital world could be
what are your thoughts on that the best
way to reduce your Tech consumption is
to create a life that you don't want to
spend on technology that's the
optimizing function that you're talking
about there if you're spending time with
your girlfriend if you're playing with
nephews you're not thinking about that I
remember four or five years ago I was
going out to see this girl in LA and I
was going to spend a ton of time Across
America and I spent pretty much like 10
days in this girl's pocket didn't look
at my phone once while I was over there
and then immediately I left and I went
to Hawaii as soon as I got to the
airport she dropped me off at the
airport soon as I get through security
and get out the other side my phone's
out of my pocket my phone was a
surrogate companion to try and
anesthetize myself away from feelings of
loneliness now there's an argument to be
made that you should be able to get used
to boredom without constantly needing
some kind of input but let's take it one
step at a time